can I present my proposed premise okay
so it's two men both of them are under
the age of 40 their forties you know
they're they're getting near there so
Gaming is something we have no
relationship to whatsoever okay I can
remember so they're brothers and so we
have Adam who had a successful career
I'm not quite sure what he was doing but
his lifestyle caught up with him he had
a lot of money a lot of beautiful women
who were at his beck and call but it
kind of caught up with him and so he's
decided to he's decided to downsize his
lifestyle and change his mindset so he
meditates a lot of carrot juice a lot of
spiritual books and so he's living in a
rent-controlled Santa Monica apartment
really nice place and then his brother
Evan needs a place to stay for a little
bit now evan has had a little bit of a
gambling issue and tends to have his own
pharmacy in his bathroom so he's got a
little bit of you know some kind of a
recovery issues that he's still working
on but Evan needs a place to stay and so
he asked to stay at the rent-controlled
Santa Monica apartment but it interferes
with Adams peace of mind and then it
turns out this rent control apartment
may be turned into a condominium and so
these different developers need to see
the place so we have Adam who's he's
working by the way for a nonprofit which
he gets 1/4 of what he made but he likes
it he feels like he's making a
difference and Evan would like to get a
job there too cuz he needs money he has
like a loan shark that he needs to pay
back and they don't really like him at
the nonprofit he's kind of loud he's
kind of boisterous he says like
off-color things it's probably not the
right yeah yeah yeah he hasn't kind of
learned you know Tasha a quick question
sure Adam made all this money does he
still have it tucked away someplace oh
you know because okay if he downsized
and he was really serious about it and
donated all the money to PETA that would
be a very different script than if you
put that all away saying someday
you know I may want to go back or I may
want to find a cause that's worthy and
it's in there making money for me or
it's no I'm living this is the new dream
I don't want to have any encumbrances I
don't want to know I could fall back on
money I want to face life every day
they'll make a big difference in the
script interesting I hadn't thought
about what his bank account look like
well that's why we have these talks okay
that's good yeah so okay so that's part
of what we get to play with them okay
great
yes because already you could start to
see the conflict if Avenue then Adam had
this money tucked away but refused to
use it so he's constantly trying to find
ways to trick a demand to loosening the
purse strings a little bit so he's
trying to constantly scam his brother no
really this this money is going to go to
to help young blind orphans from from
Kenya who are secret away by this
terrorist group and we're trying to get
them out and so you're not gonna deny
these kids are you and I have a I have a
secret contact and so if you just give
me some money I can let me sir every day
there's a new scam right away you have a
built-in source of conflict I also think
what Peters talking about is developing
sorry I touch my mic couldn't help it I
think you you have to develop the world
there's an old expression that comes
from oral esque which I don't think I've
shared yet today please keep your
clothes on there there was when the
comedians would come out on stage they
needed to give the backstory or
exposition and so they would say and
there'd be a scrim of Seville Spain and
they would say so well Abbott would say
the Costello here we are in sunny Spain
so the audience would right away be
oriented and I think I think that to
write material name a comedy premise you
have to show them the world that exists
at the time so would this be this could
be a premise pilot which means that we
see the
rather the sort of mere do well rather
moving in or could be a or it could be
at what we call a mid slice prop pilot
which we learned all about when we were
when we were working on now that's funny
and a mid slice is just it's the world
ongoing you already in the world
they're already together for a while and
later you could see the backstory and
how it happened
if I were developing this premise for
real I would try to make the brothers
even more different because what you've
got is a basic Odd Couple promise and I
mean you know I'll talk to anybody for
as long as they'll let me about Neil
Simon and what he did for comedy and how
he pushed that type of comedy forward
and you can see how many people he
influenced there's I mean Grayson
Frankie is basically an odd couple shove
you've seen it on Netflix it's amazing
mom which is a big hit that's an odd
couple situation two and a Half Men is
basically The Odd Couple with a kid so
this is kind of an odd couple' situation
but but in the Charlie Sheen John I was
blowing his last name
who was the other brother never helps
Peter elevated the brother was very
uptight and straight and Charlie Sheen
was kind of I was thinking that it made
no sense it was it was kind of out of
character for the the uptight brother
the one with the money to be the guy
that had girlfriends at his back unless
you could make that believable to me but
that the other brother didn't know how
to treat women
I'm not saying that's the way it would
necessarily go but at least you'd be
because unless you have characters who
are very very different and very very
specific you don't have conflict now
again when we be though
when we interviewed Yvette Bowser she
was great because she said when I start
I have a whole list of traits and I take
each of my characters and I run through
were they politically they left are they
right
where are they financially they
conservative the gamblers I'm what kind
of music do they listen to what kind of
so again as we take these two characters
you know my first bent is what were
their folks like was one more like mom
was one more like dad is that a
never-ending source of conflict between
him or dad always liked you better a mom
always like so all of these things go
into making up their characters and then
the trick is going to be how to not make
them to you know dimensional the carrot
brother is always good and always nice
and the other brother is always trying
to scam and always nasty so so the
scamming brother has to have a couple of
things that he does that are really
wonderful and nice or charitable and the
other guy has to everything and when
nobody's looking maybe then he takes a
little extra bosco when nobody's looking
and puts it into his carrot juice
something where they become a little
more humanized you said you're saying
you won't make them three-dimensional
yeah and and so again but the jokes are
going to come out of dimensionalizing
the character and so each time we have a
situation we know we're just talking
about this before today is that the the
Charlie Peters concept again that when
you have a third object so he gave us an
example in the book of this concept
called a third object and the example he
gave us was the deer is on a hill
there's a deer in the hill and it's it
said in Beauty and the Beast and now do
you visit aversion and beauty looks at
it said oh what a cute little deer and
the Beast is salivating Saint dinner and
so that you see the two takes of the
same object and then all of a sudden
you've totally differentiated the
characters without having to describe
them you see it in the reaction so again
as each thing happens
you know they find the wallet on the
street with money in it and one is
saying well how much did we get in the
other says how can we find we swallow it
this is so taking each event that
happens and then you're constantly
seeing the two of them taking a totally
different look through the way we
dimensionalize their characters one more
little piece of information to our
scenario is that Adam who's mister you
know meditator and you know reads a lot
of wrong das and he's just very
spiritual he used to date a woman who
was a model who he's you know since lost
contact with and their lifestyles are
totally different well unbeknownst to
him the other brother meets this model
at a bar and Adam comes back from his
nonprofit and they're both sitting on
the couch watching TV so he's met the
ex-girlfriend right first thing I would
say that is what my father taught me
which is you've got to make it
believable particularly and I said
that's even more true today in the in
the post Mary Tyler Moore post Cheers
post Fraser world which were little
Fraser was a satire but it was still
real and yet in the interim we've still
have these crappy sitcoms it makes no
sense so but the really good sitcoms the
people are believable there's a
difference between believability and
reality if I the first thing I would
change is I wouldn't have them mad at a
bar I'm gonna bark because right away
I'm saying that's a little easy if they
went to a charitable event yeah then
it's plausible times they'll be there
and then the brother happens to hit on
her and they click a little and he's got
to react to them but again Jeffrey's
made it plausible I do I see the other
note I would add is I would have the the
charity the charity the brother who
meditates and gives money to cheer me
you know maybe he runs a foundation
maybe he's not living in a small
apartment maybe it's not wearing control
that feels like a different show to me
this is what happens in a room the
yeah that's not what happens in a room
except you're there 12 to 14 hours and
the food is usually lousy but you know
and you're not serve anyone who you're
serving depending on who the showrunner
the least you could have done for these
people is serve lunch okay
drinking their water but I think that
what they knew is again it's back to
Peters thing I don't I tell students all
the time
please don't get hung up and protective
of the first idea you know develop it
feel good about hitting blind alleys
because that means you're making
progress so for me I like the idea that
the brother it was it was somebody that
he never thought he could get it it
ended and he never really knew why it
ended and they're at a charitable
charities function he's gotten the funky
brother to go with him right and and
right away there's a story for the pilot
that's a great pilot story but I think
you always have to say to yourself and
easier said than done
is this could like Crale Rosenthal could
this happen is it plausible in filius to
do I don't know if you've been watching
the history of comedy on CNN but it's
wonderful and one of the things they you
know it wasn't in our book unfortunately
Phil's in her book but he said that he
is his assignment every weekend was go
home and get in a fight with your spouse
and come back on Monday and tell me
about it oh great
so I think that's having to I think
that's kind of adding to to what Peter's
saying is find something not that's
never been done because everything's
been done and what's gonna make it
unique is your voice now the other thing
about your premise that we have to make
sure of is it's not that tough to write
a pilot episode but how are we going to
get two years worth of stories soon the
interim so I mean when we present we're
trying to sell it we can't go in there
with three ideas we have to start
showing where this can go
remembering that in a sitcom
each episode is got a little arc lit but
the can of a beginning a middle and an
end because the characters have to
endure from week to week they're gonna
want to see the carrot juice drink or
drinking carrot juice every week so he
can't change that and the other guy has
to be kind of a sleazeball druggie guy
even though he can go in and out of
detox all the time
he can have new resolves to stop each
time you know he could drink carrot
juice with his brother then go back and
get his bourbon to drink later when he's
not looking
but those characters have to endure so
that every time something happens we can
see the two of them react to it
differently let me give you an example
of a really successful show that started
in 2005 and went off in 2014 so nine
seasons many Emmys How I Met Your Mother
the two guys that created it were they
new at the very beginning of the show
they knew how the last episode would end
if you watch the nine seasons you see
how they go to that story people change
over the nine years and and because you
also have to be aware and this is
another thing I tell students because
they forget the difference between
writing a novel or writing a short story
is when you're writing anything dramatic
you're not you're primarily writing it a
to get a producer interested or you know
not in television it's not directors but
you're also writing it for actors to
speak and if an actor isn't interested
it's not gonna get made no matter how
good it is so I think people a lot of
times forget how important good dialogue
is and the only way that you can really
in the end write sitcom is if you can
write dialogue I think that you could
probably get away with writing a good
action movie if your dialogue is okay
because they're gonna hire poor Carrie
Fisher used to get hired to rewrite
dialogue at three hundred thousand a
week and Charlie
Peters used to do that work and but but
you know you just take the movie about
the tornado about 20 years with Helen
Hunt and yeah and poor Bill Paxton and
and you know they had lines alike hold
on to your seat I mean you really don't
have to write you know don't let that
table go you don't think I'm stealing
from Rob Reiner I think he was making
jokes about a play you know you can
write those kind of movies and be okay
there's no way that you can write a
great I mean the thing the best thing
about Fraser was the dialogue and how
each character nobody spoke like anybody
else it was and again it all came out of
character character traits that the
dialogue has to match the traits yeah
okay good point so let's say with our
two brothers so we have Adam who's he
chooses his words very carefully he
wants to make sure that he doesn't
offend anybody
he's totally there was a there was an
old Thomas maan book called transposed
heads where they had a holy man who
would walk through the woods with a
broom sweeping in front of him so he
didn't step on any insects he was a
Taoist okay
so again he's gonna be a character that
is so PC that it's gonna be scary right
and he wants to make sure nobody is ever
offended I have an idea okay please
Peters give me an idea
I think he should have a charity that he
I think you should have a foundation
that means he has work now that me
personally I'm just I personally I don't
know which is correct I'm tired of
seeing shows where people don't work or
we don't know anything about what they
do and I'm also tired of seeing shows
where it's all about the work so I'm
kind of a curmudgeon about this but what
if he had a foundation okay it's a it's
a 501 C 3 yeah it's gone through and
he's got the money and he's given up the
corporate life for this which goes along
with what you pitched and he wants his
brother to work right he wants his
brother to have the sense of the work
ethic that he has
and he can still and what the idea Peter
gave me is he picks a charity and I
couldn't come up with that right now but
he picks a charity said something that
nobody else would pick that is a little
bit wacky because that you get stories
out of but the you know the Daoist thing
of brushing the you know brushing the
insects out of the way is funny I'm not
saying do that but I would try to find
something that not a lot of other people
who start foundations would do you know
in foundations you get a lot of power to
choose who you're gonna give money to I
mean the the Ford Foundation is famous
for that that they have overlooked some
really good people and given money all
foundations okay but I could also see
that if you go to his office at the
foundation everything looks pretty cool
but if you know him a little better and
you go back you can't believe he's
living in a tiny little hovel apartment
well awesome it Warren Buffett so yeah
he lives a little town in Nebraska yeah
so the whole idea of you could afford to
have your own Trump Tower if you wanted
ooh yeah everything was going so great
erasing wait wait wait what I'm making a
contrast from him sheesh
see you can be too PC I think it's
called being peed on here
no but the very idea that people think
they see him in this large scale you
know incredible place for his charity
cuz he's doing everything upscale to
make the charity work not realizing that
in his own personal life he comes back
and you know he's wearing sweat pants
and he's you know sitting on the floor
doing yoga and he's got to push the
furniture aside because there's not
enough furniture to do all the postures
in the room and that's the way he wants
this austere lifestyle and then his
brother could constantly be like if he
goes to work for him saying look you
look at this Palace were working in why
are we living in this hovel
so this constantly pressure saying
loosen up loosen up the purse strings
you don't have you wear new buy new
sweatpants right right he feels guilty
so with the dialogue between the two of
them how would it be because although
they're they have
different mindsets and styles of
relating to people but they've also
known each other since they were very
young first thing it makes me think of
is Adam is hyper PC but he's human so
every once in a while when he bangs his
chin on the tub something else is gonna
come out when something makes him really
angry something is gonna come out that
all of a sudden like ooh instead of this
my middle finger just came out oh I just
spoke Italian you know so each one of
those little bursts these lapses become
very funny because it's out of character
or it's what he doesn't want him you
know he doesn't want to let that out of
himself he thinks he's purged himself of
all of that sure so it becomes much
funnier when he does it and and how on
the nose is the dialogue because they
kind of know each other with you well I
mean it seems like you know when they
say when when two people know each other
for a long time they almost don't even
have to say the full sentence they can
just say a word they can grunt and the
other person knows what that means to me
what might get but tell me what's funny
is that Evan remains consistent all the
way through but Adam went through his
transformation so he doesn't talk like
he used to and that that really pisses
Evan off saying you know what happened
the guy that I still you know play you
know play catch with in the backyard
where is he gone now everything you're
saying is no let your you know somebody
tried to prick the bubble all the time
Sims and sometimes it makes him
frustrated sometimes he takes it as a
challenge I mean I remember as a kid I
had a job working swing shift at a
credit card company in the mailroom and
one of the guys there was a Mormon and
he would bring Herman he was bringing
his lunch every day and he wouldn't hang
out with anybody else and people would
constantly try and get him angry and
like they would take a paper clip in a
rubberband go up behind him and
in the head that really hurts and
instead of getting mad and say please
don't do that that really hurts and then
all of a sudden you'd feel guilty for
doing it but you do something else
because you wanted him to curse at you
and the more he wouldn't curse the more
mean that things were that you tried to
do to get him to break so I could see
Evan constantly prodding saying how can
i how can I get him to break this facade
that I know was really a facade all
right so I just thought of something
else again he gave me particularly on
the networks but I think everywhere now
there has to be something going on well
I take Fraser for example if it had just
been the father living with Fraser and
the brothers problems I don't think the
show would have worked they needed him
to be a radio psychiatrist that was a
big part of the show you had to have
somewhere to go where you got him
because the premise of that show was
Fraser hangs him severy we could you
know hang some falls on his own what's
that expression know your own petard
yeah and he you know he would give
someone fault you know but the thing
that I think this show needs which it
doesn't quite have yet although you're
on the way we've been working on at 12
minutes that's nothing right is you need
some kind of platform there's a networks
you know in the in other words this be
more at stake than just their
relationship so so for example guys know
I was as you say we had the model before
they the two of them competing again for
the same woman who could be living next
door just as easily even I wouldn't buy
that show no no well not enough at stake
for me I mean I've seen that it's a
romantic comedy I wouldn't want to watch
that every week a big bang did okay with
that what Big Bang did okay with a
pretty good bang has the other of their
scientists and the one no I'm just
saying the fact that normally here are
two guys who don't compete one is
successful one is is on his knees
begging all the time right so to wear
what arena can they possibly
pedan there's sort of only one well the
model though she might tempt the carrot
juice meditating brother back into his
old ways but the whole point is that
would be in but but the whole point is
he's constantly monitoring himself from
going back there and I remember I had an
argument with an old friend of mine wait
wait a second hold it you had an
argument with someone who was a
fundamentalist Baptist minister and we
talked about the movie The Last
Temptation of Christ they and I was
saying Christ wins he battles his own
temptation and triumphs over it so as a
psychologist I'm saying he talked
himself out of doing something that was
bad
trying for the spirit and he said no we
believe once you entertain the thought
you're guilty of Commission of the sin
and so again this whole idea that he's
constantly battling him I've got to keep
myself pure and so she could you know
she wants to you know hey you know if
you're gonna be with me you gotta loosen
up and take a little drink you got to
take a hit on this joint you gotta you
know all the things you don't think
that's a show yet though I mean those
are all really good ideas but know about
comedy as opposed to drama comedy is
much harder to write there's no question
about that because I think people could
agree pretty much on what drama is and
isn't everybody's got an opinion about
coming but for me anyway one of the
reasons I think grace and Frankie works
if you haven't seen it do you know what
the premises Hey okay so it's two older
women in their 70s who don't like each
other
funny Jane Fonda is the sort of she was
a model and then started a very famous
business their husband or law partners
and Lily Tomlin who in real life is one
of Jane Fonda's closest friends is a
sort of hippie dippie bright woman who's
still in the early 70s and their
husbands they all go to dinner and the
women think they're going to announce
that they're retiring and instead they
they're in love they're gay and they
want to move in together and so you have
that it isn't just the two women who are
so different have to live together
because what happens is the women get
the beach house in Malibu and the men
take one of the two houses in town and I
could you know I haven't watched it
since the first season but it's really
good and what I think this is just my
opinion but what I think makes it work
is you've got both things going and
you've got more stories because you've
also got Martin Sheen and Sam Waterston
story you've got that children populated
this sitcom but it isn't just populating
it I think what a network is gonna say
if you're going to a network there's a
lot of shows on Netflix that are very
thin and still really you know there's
one show called love which is just about
a these two mismatched people who date
each other and fall in love and they
they would never be together and I lost
interest in the show after a while
because that's all it was and that's
just me but for me if I'm going to a
network with this I would have to have a
you you have to have somewhere that this
thing takes place other than the
apartment because I'm gonna get bored
and I don't know how I'm gonna get four
seasons no that's what anyone but
remember okay so as always I agree with
Jeffrey and and think for open universe
for openers you know two easy ways to go
or one they're in their 40s their
parents could still be around and so you
can have a whole new set of conflicts in
there plus they're at work and since
he's got him there at work you've got a
whole bunch of different people in there
to interact with and again you can have
people at this place of work that range
anywhere from you know they'd rather die
than see a dolphin in a tuna tuna net to
people who were saying hey let's put on
some rock shows let's really get some
glitz here let's get more celebs
involved here so I mean there's all
kinds of
but yeah but I'm saying but initially I
still want to get what are the big
conflicts between the two main
characters because they you want to make
sure they're seeing everything
differently and that their goals are
always crossed now interestingly one of
our favorite interviews in in one of one
of the 24 you mean one of our favored
one of our 24 favorite interviews and
now that's funny
was when we did Leonard Stern again who
made a big point of saying conflict as
it is it the absolute base of all my
comedy but it's never hostile it's
always out of love and we talked about
it it's kind of like it took me back
when I heard that I Love Lucy where
every episode of I Love Lucy was you
know they all love their their best
friends and each other
but they always had a conflict about
what they should be doing to express
that love yeah we should go here no we
should go there we should buy this no we
shouldn't buy this and it was always
this would be best for you listen to me
I know better but always banging heads
but not trying to hurt the other person
not competing but saying because I love
you I want what's best for you okay and
so again one of the interesting things
in this comedy that I've seen the
premise that makes it good is they are
brothers so no matter how bitterly they
fight bottom line they're gonna take
care of each other
maybe the father was successful and had
a bankruptcy and they had to downsize so
they always remembered that experience
of being on like the good neighborhood
and then for a temporary setback the dad
had to move them to maybe a rougher part
of town and to go to public school then
you lose I'm just gonna play Network
agree with anything okay and that's
that's really bad that means that
there's like a PTO says that means
they're engaged
it doesn't mean you made a sale but at
least you got them involved then as a
network exactly I would say yeah but
then you lose the foundation whereas if
the father had made a very big success
of the foundation I've never seen a show
about
foundation by the way about a about a
you know a non-profit that's like the
Ford Foundation of the Carnegie 5fc Matt
actually there was a bunch of episodes
about one in Modern Family
yeah but that wasn't the series right no
but he worked at it for like a real
estate guy who are we talking about know
one of the the red-headed gay brother
Oh worked at a faced a lawyer right and
so he worked but but anyway um you know
whatever do that and a meeting by the
way let them do that
what but they just did Oh what do you
I'm sorry we'll never tell them when
you're pitching to them what others
that's kind of passe it used to be it
used to be when you were pitching
something you would say it's
such-and-such meet such-and-such people
hate that now because they want you to
come in especially in TV I don't know
about movies but anyway go ahead down I
mean he's taking the rest of the
interview I'm not saying another word
yeah that'll be sorry let me just
interject and I don't know if I should
be doing I like in the pigeon room but
but my point was that they bonded over
having sort of a fall from grace there's
no need to go yeah and so they even
though they're at polar they're you know
their their lifestyles are different
their ethics are different they remember
those hard times cuz they got bullied in
school Jeffrey Jeffrey and I gave a
couple of talks at a a organization
called script fest and he bought me a
t-shirt that said what if the big
letters so you're doing a what if which
is great
at the in a writers room what we'd all
be doing then is saying okay what if it
was the mom that made the big success
and dad always felt weird about and what
happens if they him so there's so many
different places to take it and I
remember when when Mark and Paul did
their interview that would big March it
let you all know mark Paul lick and
Mark Shepler right yeah
and they started out with they were
doing talking about square dancing in
Arizona and they got it to how JEWS
don't square dance he so yes they do
it's a great place to meet women and
everybody go have sex after a square
dance and often they ended up with a an
outlaw harley-davidson shop with a
motorcycle gang so just just from
playing like we're playing here this was
so good but it's just the idea of you
know you kick around ideas do you see
where it goes but again for me I keep
taking it back to the two guys have to
be as opposite as we could make them and
there always has to be pressure so the
fact that he's got money and doesn't
want to use it this way and he wants the
money is a great source of pressure and
then all the different ways he tries to
get it so sometimes he looks like he's
reformed thinking he'll get it that way
and no and sometimes he sees the con and
doesn't get it so you always have that
constant pressure but underlying it
still you have the bond that their
brothers will always help each other you
know so there's caring at the same time
this really strident competition you
have a good basis and then any situation
you put them in they're always going to
see it differently Bob or C who is a big
producer writer a lot of features luck
created a lot of drama series works a
lot with JJ Abrams he told me that
post-2008 every television series that
will be on will be so influenced by and
he turned out to be right that by cable
and and now Netflix that there will be
even sitcoms will there won't there'll
be very few shows where the characters
don't grow in the old days when I
started on sitcoms you could watch a
show and then not watch ten shows and
you can come right back to it that's
going away I think and I think that's a
great thing because it
the characters can go reap is the
perfect example of that yes it's a
sitcom but and she's horrible she's I
don't know if you've ever seen it but
she's Julia louis-dreyfus Louie Dreyfus
his character is just an awful human
being but she's doing it with this wink
and a nod and it's satire so you like
her and but she changes a lot and the
situation changes but what makes that
show work is that she's the bite when
you meet her she's about to be the vice
president would be the first woman vice
president and so I was raised and this
is just you know how I was brought into
the businesses what do you call see I'm
losing words today I couldn't take a
marshmallow what is it you know when you
actually buy it you better cut this
later but the when you buy a Best
Western there really is no Best Western
chain you buy it and you get to use
their towels in their name and aw what's
that closed eyes franchise Network still
to this day talk about a franchise and
that they want to know and it's a way of
helping them get story so my vote is
that the straight brother was changed by
having to take over the foundation and
he brings the other brother in to help
him and then because he's helping him
all hell breaks loose I mean that would
be one way to go it's certainly not the
only way to go the other way is to have
them on their uppers which is what you
suggested I you know that they're broke
either way can work you know what it
really all depends on Karen is the
writer and he could because the greatest
premise in the world can be ruined by
lousy writing so and again it all goes
back to as an actor want to play this
because we're past the day when you
could get something on even Aaron Sorkin
can't get something on if a good actor
doesn't want to play it and he's a
playwright so he comes from theater he
wouldn't want to do something without
really great actors
that's why Woody Allen oh uh says two
actors hey if you don't like the words
change the words you're the actor you're
the
the ear not many writers will say that
so might might note to any writer out
there who is just starting you need you
need to know that you are writing for
actors you are not writing just for
executives you have to write dialer
that's why I get people to read it have
a reading refine your dialogue because
people read five pages and if they're
not taken they're not gonna read the
rest so I'm saying that one of the
showrunner told me recently who works
for us actually it's Bob Meyer told me
that what you want in a room is the
12:00 to 4:00 Deena takes about four
days to get a story that's why they
weren't work on multiple stories at a
time because they're on a deadline
you know the writers come back on a
network show the actors leave in June or
late May or maybe even April and then
everybody takes a hiatus and they and
the writers come back in late May early
June and they've got to get they've got
to get a head start on 24 shows so they
can't be working on one story at a time
but they break the stories in the room
and this is the first step of that and
then that the decider is the showrunner
ago you know I've seen it happen I've
been in rooms where it's happened where
where I go well you may like foundations
and you may like the brothers being rich
but nobody that's not my show and I want
it this way so there's usually a pilot
that has been written by one person not
by a staff so that the tone has been set
you know and if you have a great
showrunner like Phil Rosenthal or Bob
they want a lot of involvement but bob
says it's disagreement is wonderful
arguing and being like my idea is better
than your idea and screw you and screw
you that's not a good room to be in
that's a nasty room and does that open
but I was in a room briefly where people
topped each other and it was not a
pleasant
I tell the story about Walt Bennett
that's a great example it's gonna tell a
different story but I'll tell that one
first I take only one Zell two story I
take requests we know one white bird
when Walt was a it was a was a baby
writer in a room he he pitched a joke
and oil painting and then 20 minutes
later a more seasoned writer told the
same people to same joke everybody
cracked up and so Walt said hey I just
pitched that joke 20 minutes ago and
they said come on don't be like that
that is an excellent example of what I
was saying but one of the writers was
David Beckmann was telling us what it's
like to write on SNL and he said the the
competition is so fierce because you've
got a 90 minute show you've got two
musical episodes you've got Weekend
Update
you've got the intro where they the guy
comes in and then half of the cast at
least has standing characters that they
write for so there's only a few new bits
every week and all the writers in the
room were competing to try and get
something in those couple of little
spots so it's really fierce and if you
go long enough without getting your
stuff on the air what are we paying you
for and you're gone it was tough I've
been told that he's tough but he's right
he's right if but you can imagine the
pressure of a new writer coming in there
and it's it's a battle you know you have
to have it's like walking the streets of
New York you got elbows you know if
you're gonna get anywhere plus no one
tells you the unspoken rules and the
things because you know then you're a
threat yeah maybe you'll your story like
this foundation story will you know
supersede anything else it's but you
know there's an interesting thing that
but there was an interesting thing that
happened in here an interesting dynamic
that we'll mention for a minute which is
we you you asked us how we would
establish a story and and then in the
middle of it you said well how about if
we did this to it
and one of the ways you tell seasoned
writers from new writers a lot of
writers unfortunately when they're
pitching a story
let me intrude with the joke how many
producers does it take to screw in a
light bulb
the answer is does it have to be a light
bulb it's that terrible old Hollywood
joke but it gets to the idea that when
you're pitching a story sometimes the
producer or the exec who's listening
will start saying well could it be this
could we do this couldn't we do that and
they start to think hey whose story is
this and I'm the writer and what do you
foolish that that's as the French say an
amateur when you're a seasoned writer
and the person you're pitching to makes
any suggestion at all you say that's
wonderful
give me more because you're starting to
get a creative collaboration going
they're interested enough in what you're
saying
to want to be part of it and you want to
invite that that's the beginning of a
green light yeah
and part of the irony is half the time
they don't even remember what they said
you don't have to use it but it doesn't
matter
the minute the minute they're invested
enough to want to make suggestions
they're saying I've got something that's
hitting them yeah I tell you Bob horsey
again told me that we were well we he
came to he came to to LMU and he gave a
talk and then he followed it up by
bringing at JJ Abrams and a bunch of
other people but some one of the grad
students got up and said well you know
you've done a lot of movies you know he
did all the spider-man movies you know
start for all these things and he's and
this kid said well what if you don't
like the doubt and he said what do you
mean if I don't like the mat walk do you
have to take the note he said I have to
make sense of the note under the note so
that I can make the executive happy
because that's my boss you know if
you're you you know everybody has to
take those believe me
Spielberg still pigs now it's probably
fewer than we do but you know when we
working on this book Rudi gave us some
notes I don't I don't think that I know
for a fact Peter wasn't happy with all
of them but what Peter could do really
really well is he can he can translate
the note so that he could make the
editor/publisher happy but still kind
and that's what Bob was saying is you
have you can't turn your back on people
who are paying you and that that's sort
of a that's a young person's fantasy I
don't think there's any part of the arts
where you could do that a poet can't do
that
a nice part to talk about here is that
when you're pitching a project people
think okay did you like my work and in
many many cases they don't buy the work
you brought it but they might say but I
like the way you work I like the way you
think and they'll say we have this other
project would you be interested so
you're in there pitching yourself
sometimes more than your project and so
if you go in there saying what do you
mean it they have to be 30 years old I
had him in there was twenty four year
olds you're done then Costa said why
would we ever want to work with you yeah
there is what if you're saying hmm
30 weld that I like that you know you
have a much better chance of I say this
art Peter this morning that I believe
that we're in a period of less tolerance
for entitlement than ever before that
that JJ Abrams has a rule he and his
wife with their company that the minute
someone shows any form of entitlement
any form of you know where's my office
with the corner view on the 12th floor
by because there's just too many people
who won't behave that way and and you
know it used to be now I'm sure there
are still people who can get away with
that you know but I think unless you
looked at me when he said that I didn't
look at you I was afraid to look at you
anyway
you